rusia dice tener el control de toda la
región separatista de lugansk el
ministerio de defensa reportó al
presidente vladimir putin de la ciudad
del isi chance el último bastión que les
quedaba a las tropas ucranianas quedó
este domingo bajo su dominio
crece la atención entre israel y líbano
el ejército israelí acusó al grupo
extremista libanés hezbollah de haber
intentado atacar con tres drones un
campo de gas en alta mar en el
mediterráneo el gobierno de yair lapid
lo ve como una acción que empañan las
negociaciones de larga data sobre la
frontera marítima computa
miles de residentes fueron evacuados del
suroeste de sydney la ciudad más grande
de australia tras las vastas
inundaciones que desbordaron presas y
ríos en el área costera de nueva gales
del sur en esta zona las fuertes lluvias
cobraron al menos 20 vidas el pasado mes
de marzo
esta es una nueva actualización de
noticias en francés en 24 los acompaña
daniel hablando a mi venido comenzamos
esta emisión en ucrania rusia reivindicó
a este domingo tener el control total de
toda la región de lugansk tras haber
conquistado junto con una milicia local
separatista la ciudad del lysychansk que
se había convertido en el último bastión
de las fuerzas ucranianas en esta zona
del donbass los combatientes ucranianos
pasaron semanas tratando de defender
lysychansk y evitar que cayera ante
rusia como lo hizo la vecina hace
veredón jess hace una semana por el
momento no hay pronunciamiento oficial
de quiebre sobre esta noticia en el
siguiente informe damos un repaso a cómo
ha sido la batalla de esta zona en los
últimos días
[Aplausos]
blandiendo banderas rusas chechenas y
soviéticas se oye a estos combatientes
decir que han entrado en y si sanz los
vídeos fueron publicados en telegram por
ramzán kadyrov el líder de chechenia y
un aliado clave de vladimir putin los
vídeos corroboran las afirmaciones
hechas por rusia el viernes por
las fuerzas armadas rusas siguen
avanzando con éxito en la región del isi
tanks en los últimos tres días se ha
establecido el control sobre una planta
de procesamiento de combustible una mina
y una fábrica de gelatina el ejército
ucraniano está sufriendo grandes
pérdidas en esta región
el sábado un portavoz separatista dijo
que el isi suns que estaba completamente
rodeada afirmaciones que fueron negadas
al instante por quien los combates se
libran en los alrededores del isi chance
pero afortunadamente la ciudad no ha
sido cercada y está bajo control del
ejército ucraniano mientras rusia
intensifica sus ataques contra la ciudad
muchos residentes ya habían hundió
la ciudad ya no existe ha sido
prácticamente borrada de la faz de la
tierra
ningún centro de distribución de ayuda
humanitaria ha sido golpeado
y
muchas víctimas yo fui una de ellas
estaba cubierta de escombros la gente me
ayudó a desenterrar me el domingo el
ministro ruso de defensa anunció
finalmente la liberación total de la
región de lugansk tras la toma del isi
sans la última gran ciudad que seguía
bajo control ucraniano en la región su
conquista ahora abre las posibilidades
para el ejército ruso a avanzar hacia
asilo bians y crematorio otras dos
grandes ciudades del donbass que moscú
tiene en el punto de mira
y nos quedamos en ucrania la ciudad
oriental de slogans que el alcalde va de
liga
reportó lo que consideró el bombardeo
más poderoso registrado en el lugar
desde el inicio de la guerra los
múltiples ataques con lanzacohetes
dejaron un número todavía no determinado
de víctimas y heridos por otro lado más
hacia el norte en la frontera conjunta
al menos tres personas murieron cuatro
resultaron heridas y decenas de
residencia quedaron destruidas por
explosiones reportadas en bélgorod una
ciudad rusa ubicada a cuarto kilo a 40
kilómetros de la provincia ucraniana de
kharkiv el gobernador vyacheslav gladkov
aseguró que las causas de las
explosiones están siendo investigadas
aunque desde el legislativo ruso acusan
directamente a quién
quiero enfatizar que este ataque con
misiles fue planeado y llevado a cabo
deliberadamente contra civiles en
ciudades rusas
los activos de defensa aérea rusos
destruyeron en el aire los tres misiles
balísticos que estaban equipados con
ojivas de racimo y fueron lanzados por
los nacionalistas ucranianos contra el
corot a bloqueadores de cv para nosotros
don gordo y tras la toma de lugansk el
ejército ruso también avanza por el
resto de la región del donbass y por la
ciudad dejar kif el más reciente reporte
del ministerio de defensa ucraniano
muestra que las tropas rusas presionan
por avanzar también en el noroeste del
país nuestras enviadas especiales han
comprobado sobre el terreno el aumento
de los ataques con artillería en el
frente de ballack leia cerca de un jet
ski hasta allí se han trasladado con
voluntarios que se juegan la vida para
llevar comida a ciudadanos en las aldeas
del frente
es la línea del frente en el sur de
jarquín aquí los ataques son diarios las
aldeas que recorren esta estepas
sobreviven gracias a la ayuda
humanitaria internacional que los
voluntarios consiguen traer olec está al
cargo del convoy
de las aldeas a las que vamos a llevar
el kit de ayuda humanitaria están
destrozadas y no hay tiendas abiertas no
hay agua ni comida
y van a intentar llegar hasta el límite
con las zonas ocupadas pero para ello es
esencial seguir protocolos de seguridad
en donde se reúnen con las autoridades
locales y emprenden su camino para
llegar a los territorios de primera
línea los voluntarios tienen que parar
en varias ocasiones para cambiar de
vehículos y poder acceder así a las
zonas más peligrosas que están ocupadas
por el ejército ruso pero la artillería
ha disparado contra uno de los destinos
de los voluntarios se ve lezca imposible
llegar hasta allí hay que cambiar de
plan dejarán la ayuda humanitaria en un
lugar seguro a 10 km de los bombardeos
la localización no se puede revelar no
es la primera vez que las tropas rusas
disparan a los camiones de ayuda
humanitaria
los drones rusos vigilan y si ven autos
desconocidos intentan destruirlo si
empiezan a disparar nos si eso es local
el que recoge la ayuda y la lleva es más
probable que no le disparen por eso hoy
mañana los voluntarios solo podemos
llegar hasta aquí y dejar los productos
porque el ejército ruso está disparando
cada minuto
hasta este punto llegan también
ucranianos huyendo de las bombas galina
tiene 88 años y ha logrado escapar de
asif primera línea en esta guerra
hubo un misil que pasó por encima de mí
el sonido era ensordecedor y me desperté
en el suelo a cuatro metros de donde
estaba paseando
winston bright es muy duro vivíamos
nueve personas en una casa pequeña
notebook linkedin adquirió las tropas
rusas avanzan y presionan en su intento
de hacerse con el control de la región
del tomba si kharkiv la emergencia
humanitaria de los vecinos que están
atrapados en el frente y las zonas
ocupadas es extrema
dejamos ucrania y vamos para israel el
primer ministro interino yair lapid
acusó al grupo extremista libanés
hezbollah de haber intentado lanzar un
ataque sobre una plataforma gasífera
israelí en aguas reclamadas por ambos
países
encabezando su primer consejo después de
asumir el cargo tras la disolución del
parlamento lapiedra reportó la
interceptación por parte del ejército de
tres dones no tres drones no tripulados
en la zona el episodio amenaza con
incrementar las tensiones sobre la
ubicación de la plataforma israelí y los
esfuerzos mediados por eeuu hasta ahora
infructuosos para acordar una frontera
marítima entre ambos países
salí de test mucho ayer las fuerzas de
defensa de israel interceptaron tres
aviones no tripulados hostiles que
intentaban atacar la infraestructura
israelí en las aguas económicas de
israel es bola continúa el camino del
terror y perjudica la capacidad del
líbano para llegar a un acuerdo sobre la
frontera marítima israel continuará
defendiéndose a sus ciudadanos a sus
bienes este gobierno seguirá trabajando
por el bien de los ciudadanos como lo
hizo el año pasado
y en australia el gobierno local de
sydney ordenó este domingo la evacuación
de miles de residentes del suroeste de
la ciudad más grande del país eso tras
las intensas lluvias que desbordaron
presas y ríos en el área costera de
nueva gales del sur el ministerio de
servicios de emergencia advirtió sobre
el riesgo inminente que corren los
habitantes de la región por lo que
invitó a quienes viven a lo largo de un
tramo de 500 kilómetros de la costa este
del país que consideren cancelar sus
planes de viaje para las vacaciones
escolares
fijan el racing ya enfrentamos peligros
en múltiples frentes inundaciones
repentinas inundaciones fluviales y
erosión costera
soy firme y bien y por lo tanto se vive
en cualquier lugar entre newcastle y
weithman se ve y no se deje atrapar por
la situación climática actual esta es
una situación de emergencia
potencialmente mortal es training emails
y situación pasamos a hablar de áfrica
en libia continúan las protestas
antigubernamentales que el pasado
viernes se recrudecieron con la toma
los manifestantes dijeron que
intensificarían su campaña a partir de
este domingo instando a los ciudadanos a
instalar tiendas de campamentos en las
plazas de las ciudades y practicar la
desobediencia civil hasta lograr su
objetivo que es el de derrocar a las
instituciones políticas y celebrar
nuevas elecciones la creciente
frustración de los libios radica en la
profunda división política entre las
facciones orientales y occidentales que
han estado en guerra durante años
y en las costas de este país justamente
ocurrió el más reciente capítulo de la
crisis de migrantes que buscan llegar a
europa un bote que transportaba a 100
migrantes se hundió el pasado lunes al
intentar cruzar el mar mediterráneo 23
personas murieron pero el equipo de
rescate logró salvar a muchos de ellos
incluso a un bebé nuestros colegas de
fans de hoy nos cuentan la historia en
el siguiente reportaje
a unos 100 kilómetros de la costa libia
estos migrantes están en peligro fueron
avistados por un barco de médicos sin
fronteras una embarcación neumática
navega hacia las víctimas del naufragio
es un niño es un niño es un niño que
decía ahí
este hombre levantaba un bebé sobre sus
hombros
con la prioridad de salvar al niño el
bebé de 4 meses ya no respira
quieres que lo lleve si por favor
jac
vamos vamos a matar
el periodista que firmó los hechos
relata lo sucedido
después de unos segundos que parecieron
horas el bebé empezó a llorar de nuevo y
pudimos continuar la operación
el personal de salvamento continuó
rescatando a los adultos que aún no se
habían puesto a salvo
tenemos que moverlo más hacia la parte
trasera del barco vale vamos a ponerlo
en el barco
está bien dame tu mano
estos migrantes están aterrorizados
muchos no saben nadar 23 de las 100
personas involucradas murieron más tarde
por ahogamiento
el personal de rescate puso a salvo a la
madre del bebé y todos los
supervivientes fueron trasladados al
barco de salvamento
por precaución el bebé y su madre fueron
llevados en helicóptero a un hospital de
malta
y seguimos hablando de migración esta
vez en el continente americano el
reciente fallecimiento de al menos 53
emigrantes que habían cruzado en un
cambio en la frontera entre méxico y
eeuu deja patente la peligrosidad de
este cruce pese a los altos riesgos que
corren las personas en tránsito estos
flujos continúan un negocio que
beneficia a los traficantes marina
sardenya nos vienen los detalles
un viaje cargado de peligros pero no los
suficientes como para cesar en el
intento agarrados unos a otros para no
ser llevados por las fuertes corrientes
decenas de migrantes cruzan cada día el
río grande frontera natural entre méxico
y eeuu no yo estoy que lloró la hora de
felicidad
bastante llevamos hoy en el día 26 que
llevamos de travesía contra vez hemos
cruzado ya 6 países que hemos sufrido
hemos sufrido porque hemos hemos tenido
momentos
que ya estamos que tiramos la actual ya
no aguantamos se trata de una de las
fronteras más mortíferas del mundo como
lo demostró el reciente fallecimiento de
los 53 migrantes asfixiados dentro de un
camión en san antonio texas la
organización mundial de las migraciones
estima que el 58 por ciento del total de
migrantes fallecidos en 2021 perdieron
la vida en ese cruce ni siquiera el
endurecimiento de los controles
militares en las fronteras en el
tránsito masivo de personas muchas
viajan ayudadas por coyotes o
traficantes a los que pagan hasta diez
mil dólares el hecho que haya una visión
o una política de control y de
endurecimiento en las fronteras lo único
que hace es primero que sea más costoso
el cruce y eso quién termina ganando son
los grupos del crimen detrás de estas
redes de tráfico de personas por un lado
porque pueden cobrar más caro entre más
difícil sea pasar más caro pueden cobrar
la región vive un flujo migratorio
recortes de américa latina y
centroamérica asia estados unidos el
gobierno mexicano reportó un incremento
del 89 por ciento interanual sólo en el
primer trimestre de 2022
hasta que hace resumen informativo
quédense con nosotros
[Música]